>>Narrator: For most sixth
graders the day begins
with the shuffling of
paper and textbooks.
>>Beth: And then we're going
to put the weeds in a pile
and take them to the compost.
>>Narrator: But In
this outdoor classroom
at Martin Luther King
Middle School in Berkeley,
California students spend
their first period planting.
>>Teacher: Put it in.
That's it.
>>Narrator: Harvesting.
>>Beth: Try that one.
>>Narrator: And eating
organic delights
from their edible schoolyard.
>>Beth: Boy these are
figs, don't tell anyone.
>>Esther: Look at this!
Now, where do you think
this came from?
>>Students: The garden.
>>Esther: Right out there; so
we're making little pumpkin pies.
>>Narrator: The garden
and the adjacent kitchen classroom
are learning labs for social studies.
>>Esther: And this is
a variety from France.
The name of this is
"musique de Provence"
and that means the
"music of Provence".
>>Narrator: Math.
>>Esther: If it calls for one and
one-half cups of cooked pumpkin
and we're doubling the recipe,
then how much do we need?
>>Student: Three.
>>Esther: Three.
>>Narrator: Science.
>>Student: Why is it wet?
>>Beth: We've just
been studying this.
>>Students: Oh yeah the
rain- Water, Oh yeah.
>>Beth: The water cycle;
what part of the water cycle?
Why are there droplets?
>>Student: Condensation.
>>Narrator: And life.
>>Teacher: We're also going
to add some of the manure
from that pile over there.
>>Students: Ewwww.
>>Fritjof: When you watch these
kids in the garden classes you see
that the teachers just use every
little drop of water or dew
and every plant and
every bed to teach.
>>Beth: It likes each other because
it's attracted-- surface tension.
>>Student: Look at
the size of my drop!
>>Beth: We've been studying that
water molecules have a special bond
that creates surface tension
and so we've been doing a series
of experiments in the classroom
so it's nice to sort of see
if you can play with
it someplace else.
>>Fritjof: It seems
effortless but it isn't.
It's a high art, it's almost like
an artist who is a master violinist,
it takes years and years of practice.
>>Teacher: You understand?
>>Fritjof: So this is where we come
in with the Center for Ecoliteracy.
We train teachers and it
takes a lot of preparation
to make the garden the center of
teaching, because what you see here,
is only part of it goes
on in the classroom.
>>Teacher: Does anyone remember
why we turn the compost pile?
>>Hector: So the FBI
could breathe and stuff.
>>Teacher: What's FBI?
>>Hector: "F"...
>>Student: Fungus.
>>Hector: The fungus,
bacteria, insects.
>>The compost, I like it because
there are a lot of bugs and stuff
and I didn't know like these little
leaves it's kind of like you turn it,
it kind of dries out and then like
about one month it kind of soil.
It becomes soil and we
learned the cycle of compost.
First it becomes kind of a plant,
then it becomes kind of dry,
and the dry becomes kind of
soil, then it becomes soil
and then you grow something
and you start it over.
>>Fritjof: They are learning first
of all the basics of ecology.
They are learning about
photosynthesis,
the cycling of matter, the
diversity that supports resilience
of an ecosystem but what they
also learning is to cooperate,
to do projects together,
to build community.
Another important thing is that
the kid who is brilliant in math
or science or languages will
not necessarily be brilliant
in gardening.
And somebody who is not very
articulate but is very good
with her hands or his hands,
will be very happy in the garden
and will gain in prestige
among the class community.
>>Teacher: So this is very hot,
be careful- Okay pour it all in;
now mix it together very quickly.
>>Narrator: The edible schoolyard
concept is the brainchild
of Alice Waters who runs the renowned
Chez Panisse restaurant in Berkeley.
>>Alice: I love them
when they're mixed in.
>>Narrator: She originally conceived
the garden back in 1994 as a way
to improve on school lunch programs.
>>Alice: This is a delicious
revolution that we're talking about.
This isn't hard to do.
If they grow it, they cook
it, they want to eat it
and that there's a whole
range of foods that kids love.
>>Teacher: You see
just making it hot,
just toasting it gives
it a different flavor.
>>Alice: The kids have been
captivated by this experience
and you see them looking and smelling
and tasting and they don't think
that this is school, yet we know
what they're learning and it's very,
very fundamental, important
information.
They all know how to make
a vinaigrette for a salad.
They all know what it is to set
a table and to ask people to come
and sit down and eat together
and talk at the table.
They're learning these values
of concentration and generosity.
>>Esther: Beautiful, I'm going
to bring it right over here.
Put it down.
>>I think for our students the
biggest benefit is being able to come
to their senses literally.
>>Student: It tastes like cinnamon,
it gives you like a warm feeling
right here when you eat it
because it's nice and warm.
>>Student: Yeah, just kind of inside.
>>Student: It's really nice.
>>Esther: I think that it's
almost a sign of the times
that we have a program like this
to teach things that are so basic
that people used to learn at
home from their own families
and that's really not happening now,
and it's a very dangerous thing to be
that cut off from where
your food comes from,
knowing where it is grown, how did
it get to wherever you buy it from,
and it completes a circle
for a lot of students
who don't know the least little thing
about nature and farming and they get
to see that whole cycle and not
just see it, but make it happen.
They're the ones that
are driving the garden.
They're the ones that come in and
make it all happen in the kitchen.
>>Teacher: For closing circle
the question is one word
that describes your favorite
part of the garden this season.
>>Student: Harvest.
>>Student: Growing everything.
>>Fritjof: In middle school
they are just at the transition
between childhood and adolescence.
>>Student: The colors.
>>Student: Flower.
>>Fritjof: And there's still a lot of
the sense of magic in those children.
>>Student: Riding on a wheelbarrow.
>>Fritjof: And when they come to
the garden especially their garden
which they have planted and built
themselves they own that sense
of magic and so it is a
very, very special place.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org.